hey this is danny O'Dwyer speaking the
wonderful words of mr. kevin van oort
this is gamespot's review and progress
of destiny there's a stark and uneasy
beauty to destiny it follows forth from
the methane pools that poison Venus's
landscapes and it billows from within
the fissures crisscrossing Earth's own
moon these environments are both
stunning and lifeless playing destiny is
to move and shoot through spaces that
don't feel entirely real they are both
tremendously gorgeous and eerily
synthetic like Destiny's mechanics the
atmosphere seems designed to avoid
alienating the pickiest of focus groups
and don't take that to mean that destiny
is a negative experience thus far this
is the type of game that you would use
the word polished to describe it was
clearly expensive to make with
meticulous mechanics and fluid controls
that you rarely have to fight against
there's a halo ish feel to some of those
mechanics but this game is never as
cartoonish as that other sci-fi shooter
so in the most mechanical respects
destiny feels absolutely fantastic
taking down a Hobgoblin or a wizard with
a few shots at your pulse rifle is a
powerful feeling and your foes are
worthy ones if rather bullets bungie the
context for these encounters is slow to
build tension destiny's dialogue is
dominated by the hovering robot called a
ghost that accompanies you so the
appearance of other characters is a
welcome one nevertheless Destiny's
dialogue comes from the diablo 3 school
of cliche offering up such gems as I've
got a bad feeling about this without
enough cheeky energy for you to believe
that this could actually be a star wars
reference destiny means for you to join
others in your quests you can play on
your own but there comes a time when
doing so means a bit of grinding areas
you've already visited fortunately if
bottles get difficult most combat spaces
are eloquently designed and give you
plenty of room to find cover should you
need time to charge up your shield it's
better to find others to join you which
is easy enough to do from your friends
list then the hub area known as the
tower or even in the world at large
where you stumble upon other players if
you played the alpha or beta test you
know more or less how destiny feels
however there's little to find fault
with in this regard as for the loot the
story in the world building while the
jury is still out for now however
destiny has the look and feel of a big
budget shooter and the structure of a
lean newt driven role-playing game a
combination of borderlands poppy
and destiny greatly refines at the same
time there is a sense that you're just
going through the motions and that the
excellent mechanics just need a chance
to break free we'll bring you a full
review of Destiny soon on gamespot com